welcome back Brian
it's been two years that we've missed
you now due to covert precautions and
you not coming over the Atlantic but
here you are yeah
one of your colleagues a bit of
Weinberger certain Brian kernaghan and a
certain Alejo blew us all into the weeds
with orc it did so many things were
vaguely known about in other languages
but which I had never seen in one
package before I mean I'd force myself
to do associative arrays in snowballed
just to say I'd done them you know that
it was a joy and a delight and a mystery
and yes it did
I think was a breath of fresh air for
the community to show what a scripting
language could do I guess it's getting
rather long in the tooth now but I do
notice that every time I guess a
different Linux orc is still there it's
not something you usually have to
download it's really I guess there's a
lot of stuff out there that does depend
on having it around
but I'd just love to hear your thoughts
about what it's good for what it's bad
for and the gotchas that can sometimes
so I mean a lot of
a lot of the Youth of today hiding fans
say to me why do you use your walk at
all why don't you use Python for
everything so here's a man to ask well
it watched that long of the tooth stuff
because
none of us are quite as young as we used
to be but um no I I you're right uh it
was a hell and Peter and I worked on it
in 1977 originally a very short
development cycle and it was intended as
something that would make it really easy
to process text and numbers in the same
program with roughly equal ease or
facility
and I think it's probably the first
really widely used scripting language
you mentioned snowball four
um and certainly I was I knew of
snowball horror because it was developed
at Bell labs in fact but I'd never
really used it but that's where the the
original idea for associative arrays
Camp rep so an associate of array just
for clarification is an array whose
subscripts are not necessarily numbers
but could be arbitrary let's call it
strings of text something like that and
certainly associative arrays are a very
very useful thing and if you're only
going to have one data structure that's
the one to have because you can build
everything else with it if you want
you've done a video on that point as
well
yeah talk about long of the toothbrush
replaying our lost youth or something
like that but why would you use it today
and I think the answer is that
it's an example of what's the right tool
for a job and there's not a single tool
that works for every job some some tools
are great for across a very wide
spectrum of things and you mentioned
python Python's obviously a great uh
tool for all kinds of programming things
and I would say if you're only going to
use one program in your programming
language in your life python would
probably be the right one because you
can do so much with it and it has this
incredible ecosystem of libraries
packages modules whatever that people
have built so that's fine but there are
places where it's overkill for what you
want to do and what you want to do is
something really quick and dirty you've
got some kind of data and you just want
to see quickly something about it gee
what's in some particular column of a
collection of fields or you want to just
add up some numbers
something that you know in your heart
you could probably write in one line if
you had the right language
is the languages let you write it in one
line because it takes care of a lot of
the bank
that you would otherwise need in some
other language
python you need the baggage of
how do you get the input how do you
split it into various components how do
you write it out and all of those things
happen for free and Arc and that's one
of the reasons why Arc is
our programs tend to be very very short
compared to programs in other languages
they run at about the same speed as they
would in Python so yeah the the Gen
generally
used for short programs and very very
useful it is too but
you've got to be careful because it's
essentially a pattern match language as
to what gets done next it's not
a straightforward linear flow through
like it you can trace through a c or
even a Python program you've got to be
asking all the time okay well is this
going to pattern match oh it does what
do I do now and my worry always is that
all my inadequacy as a programmer is
shown up by the fact that the longer my
list of matches gets
the more I'm scared stiff of getting a
premature match or a too late match
because my ability to handle stacked up
regular Expressions isn't as good as
Orcs so you do have to be careful you
can get
matches you never expected right so let
me back off for a second um because
just in case people haven't seen it or
don't remember the idea you know I guess
as you say it's a pattern action
language and so in our program is a
sequence of patterns
that will match against the input and
each pattern has an Associated
actionable issues what do you do when
you see one of those in the input a
typical aquagram only has one pattern
and one action and maybe only the
pattern or the action and so you don't
run into that problem that you just
described where you've got a long
sequence of things and you have to get
the sequence right typical program is
short the patterns are obvious and yeah
have a natural sequence and so that
works out very well
but then this kind of gets back to
something you mentioned before what's
the right language for the a particular
kind of job and I think if you find
yourself writing something it's very
very very very long you know it's maybe
not the right language for it that
you're better off perhaps with something
in let's call it python or some other
language that you like the trouble is I
think is that an awk program very often
starts small you just got one or two
things to do and then you say oh but I
could do that better and you add some
more and it tends to grow as all
programs know that exactly and and so as
a result the program evolves from
something that we're very clean and
simple into a Rat's Nest of stuff and
this is true I suspect of all kinds of
programs not just in these just
different different kinds of rats nests
on it yes
do you keep it under active maintenance
in some sense and are you anyone do you
do four wall releases anymore affordable
releases is too strong what what it is
it's been on GitHub for quite a while
now and
um I haven't been doing very much active
development on it most of the actual
work is um Arnold Robbins who is the uh
actually the maintainer purveyor of gok
the gnu version of OC but Arnold is
incredibly good at this kind of thing
very very uh a good friend who is
managing among other things making sure
that Arc in the original version of it
stays up to speed as well so I think of
him as actually the person keeping an
eye on it so he's got lots of killer
test Suites Jose I've had test Suites
for a very long time and Arnold has
certainly augmented those the thing that
I've done most recently uh it's always
been embarrassment that awk only works
with ASCII or or maybe 8-bit inputs but
it doesn't really handle Unicode at all
and so a few months ago I spent
some time working with an incredibly old
program
um and and I have it at this point where
it will actually handle uh utf-8 input
and output so that you can have regular
Expressions that you know pick up
Japanese characters or something like
that and that appears to work correctly
it's sort of in a staging version on the
GitHub site at this point and so that
that that was actual real work trying to
understand old code and insert something
into it I think I've got it right but
you mentioned tests it needs more tests
yeah entirely me
um the other thing I did was just a
quick and dirty uh thing to make it
possible to handle uh CSV inputs comma
separated variables because that was
never really done and so now if you have
the kind of straightforward CSV input
cool yeah something quote it will handle
that properly on input
so
but that's that's basically all the
development I've done uh the question of
how do you test a program is is fraught
um and and obviously uh big companies
and even small companies spend a lot of
their time in resources in testing code
to try and make sure that it works
because often it doesn't uh so for a
very long time August had uh
a test Suite quite an extensive test
tweet at least for what we call amateur
programming uh with probably thousands a
few thousand tests that are all run
completely automatically so you just say
test me and it goes through and if not
if everything works according to the
test then you hear about that if you
make a mistake the tests should in
principle tell you whether it works or
not and some of the tests are regression
tests did it produce the same answer
this time as it did the last time uh
because that tells you if you change
something something broke you got to
figure out why some of them are sort of
absolute tests where this program has to
produce this output you know what the
right answer is and it's not a question
of what we did before but it there is an
absolute right answer you know one plus
one it better equal to two
um and some of those are for specialized
corners of the language like the regular
expression mechanism yeah so there's a
kind of a sub language in the testing
which says this regular expression
should match this and this and this but
should not match this and this and this
and so there's a bunch of there's
hundreds of the very early days of all
then was that what uh Al AO brought to
the party as it were what Albert was
basically regular expression technology
and understanding the regular expression
parsing in awk the recognition mechanism
is essentially the same as it is in
egress which L did as well um and it's
fundamentally uh a highly efficient lazy
evaluation of convert a
non-deterministic finite determinant
into the equivalent deterministic finite
automatic but do it in a way that you
don't get the explosion of States yeah
and so and you don't spend forever
building the recognize yes and so that
was a really really really nice piece of
work the code is pretty
what's the correct technical word
inscrutable yes but yeah but I uh
fortunately I was able to figure out
enough of it out that I could put in the
UTF
processing Unicode processing inside
well done you yes but Al had been
interested in regular expression
technology for a long time so for our
fans who don't know who our aho is I'll
leave it to you Brian it's from Finland
isn't it uh no he's actually from Canada
but a Finnish Heritage somewhere back in
time on his family it was finished and
uh I if I recall correctly he actually
speak some Finnish but it's not his
native language at this point he's
dreadfully difficult to hyphenate in
Finnish he once told me well it's a
nightmare yes but do carry on so going
back again into the midst of time
um Alejo was in fact an undergraduate at
the University of Toronto a year ahead
of me he was a graduate student at
Princeton a year ahead of me he went to
Bell Labs a year ahead of me and we were
in essentially almost adjacent offices
at that point and he's been variously my
boss and of course Frankfurt at this
point creeping up on 60 years
but uh Al was very much interested in
formal language stuff and that's I think
we're part of the interest in regular
Expressions came from and then he did
his PhD thesis at Princeton that sort of
thing and a lot of the work that he did
on language
design and implementation to compiler
technology theoretical as well as
practical I was actually recognized he
got the Turing award last year along
with Jeff Allman so obviously very
serious computer science person that as
well as a super nice guy yes so he's LDA
in orc yes yeah and the W is Peter
Weinberger who uh at the time we did it
I occurred to me uh just as I was sort
of thinking about what we might talk
about today it occurred to me that Al
and Peter and I were in a sequence of
offices adjacent so the name is just
obvious actually it's a pretty lousy
name but it's it's okay no it's fine I
mean I I suspect you didn't mind your
initial coming last although that's not
alphabetically correct largely because
you can't think of any other sea bird
called an aqua or something yeah
Peter uh joined Bill Labs a few years
after L did and after I did but by just
luck of the draw very excellent luck he
wound up in this office between us and
uh so we worked on this together Peter
has uh spent time at Renaissance
Technologies in New York hedge fund kind
of thing and then uh has been at Google
for a very long time at this point
working on things like go and so on but
superb mathematician and cryptographer
kind of person in the background yeah
oh
well I I'm flabbergasted I just
obviously I'm not keeping myself up to
date I didn't I did not realize that Al
had been given the ACM touring award
well very well deserved because I think
one of the things that really struck me
about all that he's done on eogrep and
therefore behind the scenes on organson
is that um he is remarkably pragmatic at
times and not theological about it at
all a number of of his own rules as it
were that he just breaks because you can
you can see immediately that on a
problem this small it's not going to
lead you into huge overheads and so on
um I mean there are so many things in
egrep that a purist would disapprove but
that's his great strength I think oh yes
in fact I came from a sequence of ideas
one of which was grep which is the
pattern matching program which I'm sure
we've talked about in the book you've
done one on that where did rap come from
you've done it yes so we did that one
one of the basic things in grep is the
regular expression the pattern that you
are looking for that is what grep is
looking for in the input so egrap where
e is extended basically said let's take
the patterns that grep supports which is
a particular class of regular
expressions and let's extend it to a
broader class of regular Expressions
that are harder to recognize and that's
what Al did he took his expertise in
automata for recognition and made this
thing which was a combination of
excellent Theory and excellent practice
and that is the program called egrep
yeah
and then Ark takes some of those ideas
the patterns in Ark one class the
patterns are regular expressions
which are of the egrap class so that you
can recognize very sophisticated kinds
of patterns with uh an arc program
and it's not the only kind of pattern
but but things that involve very good
Expressions use that Egret mechanism and
in fact the code in Arc probably was
just transliterated by L from what he
had in egrip and then made to fit the
framework within awk right from the very
beginning your releases of Unix have had
no end of text processing Tools in one
source and another but what sort of
texture bases were you drawing from what
what were the problems you were trying
to solve and this yeah that's a great
question I think and this is a place
where memory probably failed in some
sense but clearly you start from the
beginning it's a programmer's
environment Unix is a programmer's
environment so you need program you need
a program like a text editor to be able
to edit the text of the programs that
are going to run on your system the
operating system itself and all of the
applications so you're manipulating text
at kind of minimum level
then you need to be able to find things
in text of whatever sort and so the
Genesis of grep which we've talked about
is just to take the text editor rip out
the uh
preserve the regular expression pattern
matching part of it uh I think a further
extension of that then was Lee McMahon
was very interested in uh basically
linguistic stuff I think he was
fundamentally linguist as opposed to a
computer science type and he wanted to
be able to process text and he had
things like The Federalist Papers which
at the time where G is a megabyte or two
of data that's huge yeah and today is
down in the noise but he wanted to be
able to process those things and those
were too large to fit in the text editor
of the time so he built this thing
called The Stream editor said so that he
could stream The Federalist Papers past
a sequence of editing commands to
extract information that he wanted or
modified along the way
um and so that was I think one of the
things that came into awk this idea that
you could process text very easily with
programs like grabman said but could you
do more with it
um and so I think that's part of it and
then other people start to be interested
in text as well uh for example spelling
correction or spelling mistake detection
not correction that Doug McElroy was
very interested and for that you have
things like well you've got text that
people are writing because people were
writing technical papers they were
writing books and we had a dictionary
that's all of this
again fed into the there's lots of text
you need tools to process it and and
then the other side of that I guess was
the formatting stuff of you've got text
and you want to print it neatly and
that's where you and I yeah started long
ago and interacting on how do you
process text to make it nicely formatted
but I think in many ways it's that that
emphasis has been in your favor because
I remember the culture shock of coming
to Unix which is simply wonderful and
coming from the background although
frankly you just didn't figure in the
Computing firmament unless you'd really
come from a background of inverting 100
by 100 matrices in less than a second
and this sort of thing you know it was
such a refreshing I mean text for many
years really before Unix came along with
its tools was definitely a second if not
a third class citizen uh and if you
weren't careful you'll be taken away in
a wagon labeled COBOL or something like
this and it wasn't seen as being part of
everybody's concern to want to go have
good text handling tools I think there's
two parts there one is a big part of
computing originally was engineering
computations scientific computations for
which Fortran was great but Fortran is
terrible for text right the other side
of it was let's call them business
computations like I want to send out
invoices I want to do payrolls and
things like that and Cobalt is good at
that kind of structured record-based
stuff and it's terrible at lots of other
things
um and so there was this kind of Gap
there or set of applications which were
neither scientific computations nor
business computations but they just
involved taking you know strings of
characters and showing them yeah and I
think Unix fit that almost by accident
perhaps because the machines were too
small to do any serious scientific
computation the early Unix machines
didn't even have floating going Hardware
no all right and so it was hard to do
that kind of thing and nobody had any
interest in business computations of the
Cobalt sense I think I do remember it
was a huge culture shop for me but came
across Cobalt and it finally dawned on
me that a lot of my problem in
understanding what it was doing was that
it was actually doing arithmetic on what
came down to being character
representations rather than pure binary
in fact if you wanted it in pure binary
you had to ask for it to be done that
way and I thought I mean it hadn't come
from as you say a physical sciences
background I thought what other way is
there other than the whole thing a
floating Point numbered so many places
and then several it's a fine because
it's like a halfway house between that
and what we're talking about associative
arrays is treating characters as
first-class citizens for a change yeah
no Cobalt certainly did that although it
tended to be if I recall I haven't
written Cobalt for a very long time
fixed record links there was no not
something that's right but the other
thing is so if you want to do Financial
computations you have to do them
accurately and floating point is not
right the pennies because otherwise you
know Sean
you're doing all this wonderful stuff
then on all coming you're not just going
to sit on it and not release it
presumably there is going to be a formal
release for this and this bountiform
questions like uh in what uh text
processing language will you be writing
this new Endeavor then if it's not you
know written in orc itself
right yeah so I think part of the
trigger for trying to do Unicode in uh
art was conversations that I've had with
Alan Peter and our editor at Edison
Wesley but whether undue version of the
awk book would be appropriate the art
book came out in 1988 so it's getting
kind of long in the tooth as well
um and so I thought what the heck a
summer project while I'm on vacation in
England would be to work on the a new
version of the art book that would
you know deal with things like well we
can now represent Unicode characters at
least plausibly but I think more
generally the Computing environment is
just incredibly different today than
what it was 35 or 40 years ago machines
are you know 100 to a thousand times
faster memories are a million times
bigger and that changes the way you
think about things it used to be that
you couldn't afford to run awk programs
on big data now that's not true it
processes megabytes in milliseconds and
so uh that changes the trade-offs that
you might make it changes the when do
you move from let's say OCTA python to C
or C plus plus or that kind of thing and
so
so I've been doing you know in the
background playing with a new version of
the awk book which one hopes we'll see
the light of day but I don't I'm not
going to commit to a schedule thank you
um and I I guess the related question is
what technology do you use to produce
such a book when we did the first book
this was kind of the high point of tools
like t-roth and the related specialized
languages that that you and I have
talked about over the years
um but what what's today that we would
do trough itself is at this point you
know kind of pretty much unmaintained
although there is the wonderful giraffe
uh that James Clark did that is
absolutely a beautiful piece of work
compatible with t-roth but at the same
time lots of useful extensions that make
it a lot easier to actually use in
practice
um and so what I've been using is g-roth
yeah and the associated things like the
table processor and the picture
processor and so on that were all done
as part of that uh the big problem is
that t-roth doesn't really handle
Unicode output very well and so I have
yet to figure out the proper mechanism
for that that's on the list shall we say
and I'm
I'm not sure what to do both I genuinely
don't know yes we have James talk a big
vote of thanks absolute stuff
to my amazement you haven't decided to
transliterate it it's all into later I
can do it that way I'll let Shawn edit
that one out as seamlessly as he can no
but but you raise an interesting
question I I literally yesterday I was
looking at a version of tech which uh
claims to support Unicode full Unicode
with full proper uh Unicode character
sets that is the glyphs that you could
actually put on paper or in a PDF file
um
and I at some point maybe that's the
right way to go I honestly don't know
but that's a very active uh piece of
work I think it's called xitech
ztec I'm not sure how it's pronounced
um but to Tech has a very very very big
operation and I was going to download it
as an experiment and they wanted five
gigabytes and five gigabytes at the
particular out in the boonies place I'm
living would not be finished yet and so
I'll wait till like yeah yeah yeah to
investigate it yeah but if somebody else
has done the work then I think that I
could with a program not a knock
probably in Python convert what I've got
into something that would be proper
intact input for a tech like latex or
whatever
um and that way somebody else would be
doing the heavy lifting but at this
point I honestly just don't know the
last version of the book was in 1988 so
uh so my question is where do you store
stuff like that because is there like a
floppy disk lying around somewhere
some of these things you just carry with
you over multiple versions of computers
and so I actually still have all of this
stuff I think
I think I might even I have the post
script I think that we used for that
that
predates PDF I've got no end of stuff in
that room there related to rescuing your
vacation memo and getting an early
enough version of t-roth that would cope
with it without me having to change the
source code at all you just got to get
the fonts all lined up in the way they
used to be and uh actually what has
always struck me with this is that when
you have there's some vital component
that was part of a release from Bella
probably had to pay a fortune for it
nowadays if you just dare won't use the
verb grep for it some kind Souls made it
publicly available
rescued me so many times yeah and
particularly going back to those you
know very early days you think oh my
gosh here were here was my version of
the MS macros what was it like at Bell
Labs at the time you can usually find
out you can often find out yeah the Unix
Heritage society's done a marvelous job
of collecting uh all all software yeah
over much of the history of Unix as far
as I can tell and then some people are
as a laborator of Love picked up a piece
of code at some point and carried it
forward and made it still work I found a
version of graph I couldn't get my own
version of grab to work but I found one
on the web and somebody got it and it
made it work and it produces essentially
the same output so I've forgotten the
name but I'm grateful to him or her
oh of course I remember now I've used it
quite a bit but not just recently yes
yeah
to then one of them might be a little
bit bigger and one of them would be a
bit smaller but they'll multiply
together I'll just say thanks to Steve
for our second camera over there thanks
for showing for our first camera over
there sorry for walking again will it be
at least twice as good because it's got
two cameras I mean